[Musique]
nationale
celui dont un silence complet des trains
des gares sur nationale qui est
transmise par les libyens
françaises français
mes chers compatriotes de france et
d'outre-mer
ce jour
de 2002 est marquée par trois événements
importants
le premier ce record d'abstention dans
une élection présidentielle
le deuxième c'est la disparition du
parti communiste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà je crois qu'on a un problème de
son avec saint cloud et avec jean marie
le pen est ce qu'on va retrouver le son
là bas ou pas
non pas pour l'instant les électeurs de
france et d'outre-mer qui m'ont fait le
cadeau inestimable de leur confiance au
maire qui contre toutes les pressions et
les menaces ont parrainé ma candidature
o
o militants nationaux qui ont répondu
par le calme le courage le dévouement la
fidélité l' enthousiasme aux injures ou
violences et se sont dépensés sans
compter
allant parfois jusqu'au sacrifice de
leur vie à tous les amis s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît nous nous trouverons
ensemble tout à l'heure à tous les amis
étrangers de la france dans le monde et
d'abord la seule la francophonie qui
compte sur l'indépendance de la france
éternelle
comme il n'y a pas de joie parfaite je
veux saluer aussi la mémoire de rolande
bergie que vous connaissez tous sous le
nom de béret bleu grande résistante
patriotes qui avaient reçu le titre de
juste après la deuxième guerre mondiale
et qui s'est éteint ce matin au moment
où elle allait quitter l'hôpital pour
voter
n'ayez pas peur chers compatriotes
rentrer dans l'espérance
l'événement c'est le 5 mai en attendant
n'ayez pas peur de rêver vous les petits
les sans grades les exclus ne vous
laissez pas enfermer dans les vieilles
divisions de la gauche et de la droite
vous qui avez supporté depuis 20 ans
toutes les erreurs et les malversations
des politiciens vous les mineurs les
métallos les ouvrières et ouvriers de
toutes ces industries ruiné par l'euro
mondialisme de maastricht vous les
agriculteurs aux retraites de misère est
acculé à la ruine et à la disparition
vous aussi qui aide les premières
victimes de l'insécurité dans les
banlieues les villes et les villages
j'appelle les françaises et les français
quelle que soit leur race leur religion
ou leur condition sociale à se rallier à
cette chance historique de redressement
national
sachez que homme du peuple je serai
toujours du côté de ceux qui souffrent
parce que j'ai connu le froid la faim la
pauvreté je veux reconstruire la
cohérence de notre grand peuple français
l'unité de la république l'indépendance
de la france notre patrie rétablir bien
sûr la sécurité sur l'ensemble du
territoire national et libérer nos
compatriotes du fiscalisme et de la
bureaucratie
je salue fraternellement tous mes
compatriotes français qu'ils se soient
abstenus ou qu'ils aient voté pour
d'autres candidats je les invite à ne
pas se laisser manipuler par les vieux
trucs des politiciens qui veulent
conserver leur petite boutique je suis
socialement à gauche économiquement à
droite est plus que jamais nationalement
de france mais surtout
mais surtout je suis un homme libre un
patriote qui n'a qu'une ambition la
france et les français j'appelle au
rendez-vous de la fraternité française
place et avenue de l'opéra le 1er mai
fête de jeanne d'arc et des travailleurs
de france pour préparer ensemble la
deuxième étape de la renaissance
française
le deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle celui de la victoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]